Speaker 1: We have new reporting from ABC's
Jonathan Karl, which reveals that Donald
Trump actually threatened the Republican
Party with leaving the Republican Party
on January 20th as he was flying out on Air Force
One for the last time. These are unbelievable
details from Jonathan Karl in his new book. This
is a book in which the book is called Betrayal,
the final act of The Trump Show. And in the
book, Karl reports that Trump went to the GOP
chairwoman, the chairwoman of the Republican
Party, and said on January 20th, I'm leaving the
party and I'm creating my own party, and I don't
care if this destroys the Republican Party. Now,
Trump hasn't done that. And the book
recounts that Trump ultimately backed down,
but only when Republican leaders threatened Trump
with what really hurts him, which is his finances.
That's really ultimately what Donald Trump cares
about. Now, the details of the incident are
unbelievable. This reportedly took place on
January 20th up on Air Force One, as Donald
Trump was quite literally taking his final flight
out as president of the United States. Here's a
quote from Jonathan Karl's book. RNC Chairwoman
Ronna McDaniel called to wish him farewell. It was
a very unpleasant conversation. Donald Trump was
in no mood for small talk or nostalgic, nostalgic
goodbyes, Karl writes. He got right to the point.
He told her he was leaving the Republican Party
and would be creating his own political party. The
president's son, Donald Trump Jr., was also on the
phone. The younger Trump had been relentlessly
denigrating the Republican National Committee
for being insufficiently loyal to Trump. In fact,
at the Jan. six rally before the Capitol riot,
the younger Trump all but declared that the
old Republican Party didn't exist anymore.
It then got very real with the following exchange
quote I'm done, Trump told McDaniel. I'm starting
my own party. You cannot do that. McDaniel told
Trump. If you do, we will lose forever. To which
Trump responded, Exactly. You lose forever without
me. I don't care. This is what Republicans deserve
for not sticking up for me. McDaniel said This
isn't what the people who depended on. You deserve
the people who believed in you. You'll ruin your
legacy. You'll be done. But Trump said he didn't
care. Call, Karl writes. So first of all. Not,
Lloyd, the party wasn't loyal to me, Trump says
what he means by that is. They didn't do enough,
as he sees it, to steal an election that he lost
back. They didn't. They didn't execute the coup
that Donald Trump wanted executed. Joe Biden won.
And the Republican Party, as Trump sees it,
should have figured out a way to give him
another four years in the White House. Anyway, so
that's what's at issue here, which is it's mind
blowingly childish. So a few different things.
Number one, this is completely on brand for
Donald Trump. There's there's nothing surprising
that this is Trump is a if I've got to leave the
sandbox, I'm going to poop in it so that nobody
else can play in it. I'm going to shut the whole
thing down. Number two, it confirms that Donald
Trump doesn't care about people who he sees as no
longer being useful to him, so this applied to his
supporters. This applied to donors who he fleeced,
claiming the money is going to go to recounts
and artists and all these different things,
and it applies to elected officials as well. If
you're not going to or you're going to refuse to
or whatever to steal the election, for me, you're
now no longer useful to me, either. Neither is the
party, so I'll just leave. And number three, it
also confirms that Republicans are essentially
Trump's accomplices. They may privately believe
whatever about Donald Trump, and some of them
obviously don't like Trump. Some we know, and some
haven't said it publicly. But it makes sense that
some of them don't like Trump, but they begged him
to stay rather than leave, and they recognize the
damage that Trump could do. I don't think Ronna
McDaniel is wrong if Trump did start his own party
at least in twenty two and twenty four. He
could single handedly lead to Republicans
losing everything and losing badly by siphoning
off a portion of the of the Republican electorate.
Creating a Three-Way Three-Way race is which
Democrats unilaterally win and the number
four. It also confirms that Trump in the future is
going to do what he sees as best for himself. It
might be bad for the Republican Party. Trump was
not a Republican much of his life. He concocted
this whole Republican persona in order to
run, and we've talked about that before,
and Trump is going to continue doing what's best
for him. And it might conflict with what's best
for the Republican Party. If Trump might
do something next year or the year after,
that would be bad for the Republican
Party. Not only should be let him do it,
we should encourage him to do it. If he only
if if he followed through with this threat,
the left would be in a far better position going
into 22 and 24. But Trump did not ultimately
leave the Republican Party because at the end of
the day, he accepted and recognized and agreed
that it would be bad for him financially to do
that. Trump has never really been a Republican.
Trump serves his interests. He has his own
agenda. That's all he cares about. And right now,
he seems to be trying to keep his stranglehold
on the Republican Party because he knows that he
needs their money if he wants to run in 2004. And
at least for now, he has more to gain by remaining
a power player in the Republican Party than by
abandoning it. Because remember, if Trump abandons
the Republican Party and starts his own, it's bad
for Republicans, but it's also probably a losing
bet for Trump. It's really best for Democrats
and the left to the extent that the left is.
Existing within the Democratic Party as
soon as and if it becomes clear to Trump.
That it would be good for
him to do that financially
and from a PR standpoint. He will do it. The guy
doesn't care. And just incredible, incredible
stories here in Jonathan Karl's forthcoming
book, which I think I think might be out next
week or the week after. We'll have more on this
on The David Pakman Show Instagram, which you
can find at The David Pakman Show on Instagram.
You can also find me on Instagram at David Pakman